le marathon législatif sur la réforme
des retraites s'intensifie cette semaine
après son passage en conseil des
ministres le 24 janvier le projet de loi
contesté pour créer un système universel
de retraite par points est présenté au
parlement ce lundi
mardi une commission spéciale de 70
députés doit se réunir sous la
présidence de la députée de la
république en marche brigitte
bourguignon pour étudier le texte
les hostilités débuteront ce soir avec
l'audition de laurent pietra chez ski
secrétaire d'état chargé des retraites
mercredi les partenaires sociaux seront
entendus puis la parole sera donnée aux
députés pour auditionner le conseil
d'orientation des retraites ainsi que
leur comité de suivi
de son côté la majorité présidentielle
espère que le vote solennel sera actée
dès le 3 mars
quelques jours avant le début de la
trêve parlementaire pour les municipales
le parti socialiste les insoumis les
communistes veulent faire obstruction au
projet avec une motion de censure plus
de 22 milliards en demandes ont déjà été
déposées d'où environ dix neuf mille par
la france soumise
malgré les différentes tractations la
majorité assure être prête et ne pas
avoir peur comme l'a affirmé le premier
ministre edouard philippe
la direction du groupe la république en
marche appelée à une certaine modération
dans les amendements
cette rapporteurs ont déjà été désignés
la majorité a aussi promis de travailler
que ses partenaires politiques des
députés modem udi et agiront été nommé
rapporteur
prochain rendez vous le 17 février dans
l'hémicycle en attendant l'examen du
texte par le sénat à partir de fin avril
[Musique]